welcome back to the show we did have
that rare very last-minute guest
cancellation today I think we can say
maybe partially related to coronavirus
although I guess we're not completely
sure right now but as a result we're
gonna just take a few phone calls it was
impossible to find a replacement guest
on short notice so let's go right to the
phones and start with our caller from
the 6:03 area code 6:03 possibly our
is-6 there at zero three New Hampshire
is that is that it yes it is can you
hear me David yes I can hey great yeah
that is me I'm sure I said too quick
very good comments last questions I just
want to get feedback on the first is
they're both black rotavirus
unfortunately but my first thing is you
know I've agree with everything you've
said for the most part obviously Trump's
handling has been pretty pretty absurd
but but the thing I keep hearing is that
earlier action would have been better
you know if we had shut things down
quicker if we had you know banned travel
quicker whatever it just seems like
that's a little bit unfair because of
course that's true you know you could
always look back and say we should have
done stuff more seriously you know taken
taken more swift action just hardly
seems like an insight to me I feel like
at the time we had done more drastic
action
you know shutting down the economy
banning all travels from China something
like that back in January would have
seemed like an overreaction you know it
just seems very difficult to know how
these would have played out I'm some
trace key reaction on that just just
feeling like it's almost tautological to
say well listen yeah you're right about
one thing which is it's always much
easier to Monday Morning Quarterback and
in retrospect it all seems so much
clearer so on the specifics of saying
travel obviously should have been banned
much earlier it's not the fairest
criticism but the truth is that by the
time Trump ban traveled from China the
focus had really moved to Europe and by
the time Trump did that you know a lot
of people were late on that it wasn't
just Trump I think the fairer criticism
is the things that weren't done are
things that the pandemic response team
would have done which trump disbanded
and that includes you develop a test
much sooner South Korea did it South
Korea and the US had their first confirm
case within 24 hours South Korea
immediately developed a test mass tested
isolated and contact traced they still
don't have 200 deaths and we had over a
thousand deaths yesterday alone that's a
fair criticism that should have been
done earlier the mobilization and plan
for the strategic stockpile of
ventilators and masks etc Trump was
waylaid on that you need to early
identify and start mobilizing those
resources so the travel ban criticism
alone is some kind of 20/20 hindsight to
some degree that is not totally fair but
there's such a longer list of things
that should have been done and would
have if the pandemic response team
hadn't been disbanded yep
no I totally agree I think that's that's
very well put and it's one very quick
other comment I think the the only other
element that seems like a little bit of
an unfair criticism it again just want
to get your take on and them but that's
it there it just related to the
ventilators and the stockpiles and
things like that that you mentioned I
mean you know we all know Bill Gates
gave that TED talk on how you're
unprepared the system was for a pandemic
back in 2015 and obviously Trump's just
blaming Obama it's really just kind of a
political stunt you know some bombs fall
it's kind of every president I guess you
could say leading up to this point but
it does seem like that's something that
doesn't come into play i mean e-to the
US as a whole the federal government
seems very unprepared for something like
this managed from a federal level and we
obviously just have a very bad leader in
charge now to be handling it but it also
seems like you know again that's just
the other criticism I see that sometimes
I see you laid out very unfairly they'll
say something like how did Trump not
know you know and and keep the stocks
also low that also doesn't seem fair so
that's when we began you take on that
and that's it well again I think that
the size of the stockpile is 5% of the
criticism 95% is getting rid of the
pandemic response team not having a team
in place to start
strategically thinking about growing the
stockpile starting in December and
mobilizing the stockpile where now you
have States making requests some states
get requests filled some don't so the
the size of the stockpile alone is only
about 5% of the criticism even if you
say that it's completely unfair that
still leaves another 95 percent
sure sure all right thank you so much
for the call I really appreciate it
great to hear from our friends our
friendly neighbors to the north
northwest north I guess in in New
Hampshire